so we're in a real live war at a moment
and it's a war that were truly losing
it's a war on superbugs so you might
wonder if I'm going to talk about
superbugs why I'm showing you a
photograph of some soccer fans and
Liverpool soccer fans celebrating a
famous victory in Istanbul a decade ago
well in in the back in the red shirt
well that's me and next to me and in the
red hat that's my friend Paul rice so a
couple of years after this picture was
taken Paul went into hospital for some
minor surgery and he developed a
superbug related infection and and he
died and you know I was truly shocked he
was a healthy guy in the prime of life
so there and then and actually have a
lot of encouragement from a couple of
tedsters I declared my own personal war
on on superbugs so let's talk about
superbugs for a moment so the story
actually starts in the 1940s with the
widespread introduction of antibiotics
and since then a drug-resistant bacteria
have continued to emerge and so we've
been forced to develop newer and newer
drugs to fight these these new bacteria
and this vicious cycle actually is the
the origin of superbugs which is simply
bacteria for which we don't have
effective drugs and I'm sure you'll
recognize at least some of these
superbugs these are the more common ones
around today last year around 700,000
people died from super bug related
diseases but look into the future if we
carry on and on the the path we're going
which is basically a drugs based
approach to the problem the best
estimate by the middle of this century
is that the worldwide death toll
from superbugs will be 10 million at 10
millions of just to put that in context
that that's actually more than the
number of people that died of cancer
worldwide last year so seems pretty
clear that were not on a good road and
they and the drugs based approach to
this problem is not working so I'm a
physicist and so I wondered could we
take a physics based approach a
different approach to this problem and
in that context well the first thing we
know for sure is that we actually know
how to kill every kind of microbe every
kind of virus every kind of bacteria and
that's with ultraviolet light and and
we've actually known this for more than
a hundred years so I think you all know
what ultraviolet light is it's part of a
spectrum that includes infrared includes
visible light and the short wavelength
part of this group is ultraviolet light
and the key things from our perspective
here is that ultraviolet light kills
bacteria by a completely different
mechanism from the way that drugs kill
bacteria so ultraviolet light is just as
capable of killing a drug-resistant
bacteria as any other bacteria and
because the ultraviolet light that is so
good at cutting all bugs it's actually
used a lot these days to sterilize rooms
sterilized working surfaces and what you
see here is a surgical theatre being
sterilized with germicidal ultraviolet
light but what you don't see in this
picture actually is is any people and
there's a very good reason for that
in that ultraviolet light is actually a
health hazard so it can damage cells in
our skin cause skin cancer can damage
cells in our eye cause I diseases like
like cataract so you can't use
conventional germicidal ultraviolet
light when there are people around and
of course actually we want to sterilize
mostly when there are people around so
the ideal ultraviolet light would
actually be able to kill all bacteria
including superbugs but would be safe
and for human exposure and actually
that's where my physics background
kicked into this story so together with
my physics colleagues we realized there
actually is a particular wavelength of
ultraviolet light that should kill all
bacteria but should be safe for human
exposure and that wavelength is called
far UVC light and it's just so this
short wavelength part of the ultraviolet
spectrum so let's let's see how that
would work so what you're seeing here is
this is the surface of our skin and I'm
gonna superimpose on that some bacteria
in the air above the skin so now we're
going to see what happens when
conventional germicidal ultraviolet
lights impinges on this so what you see
is as we know germicidal itis is really
good at killing bacteria but what you
also see is that it penetrates into into
the upper layers of our skin and it can
damage those key cells in our skin which
ultimately when damaged can lead to skin
cancer so let's compare now with far UVC
light same situation skin and some
bacteria in the air above them so what
you're seeing now is that again far UVC
lights perfectly fine at killing
bacteria but what fire we see I can't do
is penetrate into our skin and there's a
good solid physics reason for that but
fire UVC light is incredibly strongly
absorbed by all biological materials so
it simply can't go very far now
viruses and bacteria are really really
really small so the far UVC light can
certainly penetrate them and kill them
but what it what it can't do is
penetrate in the skin and it can't even
penetrate the dead cell layer right at
the very surface of a skin so far UVC
light should be able to to to kill
bacteria but kill them safely so that's
the theory it should work should be safe
what about in practice
does it really work is it really safe so
that's actually what our lab is been
working on the past five or six years
and I'm delighted to say the answer to
both these questions is an emphatic yes
yes it does work but yes it is safe so
I'm delighted to say that but actually
I'm not very surprised to say that
because it's purely the laws of physics
at work so let's talk to the future so I
mean I'm thrilled that we now have a
completely new weapon and actually I
should say an inexpensive weapon in our
fight against superbugs so for example I
see far UVC lights and surgical theaters
I see far UVC lights in food preparation
areas and in terms of preventing the
spread of viruses I see far UVC lights
in schools preventing the spread of
influenza preventing the spread of
measles and I see fire UVC lights in
airports or airplanes preventing the
global spread of viruses like h1n1 virus
so back to my friend Paul rice so he was
actually a well-known and well-loved
local politician in his in my hometown
of Liverpool and they put up a statue in
his memory in the center of Liverpool
and there it is but me I want Paul's
legacy to be a major advance in this war
against superbugs and armed with the
power of light that's actually within
our grasp thank you
the State Fair had ever the question it
occurs to be David so tell us where what
where you're up to in developing this
and what are the remaining obstacles to
trying to roll out and realize this
dream well I think we now know that it
kills all bacteria but we sort of knew
that before we started but we certainly
tested that so we have to do lots and
lots of tests about safety and so it's
more about safety than it is about
efficacy and we need to do short-term
tests and we do need to do long-term
tests to make sure you can't develop
melanoma in many years on so those those
studies are pretty well done at this
point
the FDA of course is is something we
have to deal with and rightly so because
we certainly can't use this in the real
world without FDA approval I mean are
you trying to launch this first in the
US or somewhere else we're at you in a
couple of countries in Japan and in the
u.s. both and have you been able to
persuade biologists you know doctors
that this is a safe approach well as you
can imagine there is a certain
skepticism because everybody knows that
UV light is is it's not safe so when
somebody comes along and says well this
particular UV light is safe you there is
a barrier to be crossed but the data are
there and I think that's that's what
we're going to be standing on well we
wish you well this is potentially such
important work thank you so much for
sharing this with us thank you David
[Applause]
[Music]